ich bin angesichts dieses voll versagens
nur noch schockiert über diese
schönrednerei die wir da gerade wieder
erlebt haben das muss man sich mal
vorstellen da stellt sich der berliner
bürgermeister michael müller hin und
spricht ernsthaft von einem
paradigmenwechsel lobt die impfzentren
obgleich wir beim impfen völlig versagen
und beim testen völlig versagen
da stellt sich markus söder der
bayerische ministerpräsident hin und
spricht von der erleichterung dass sich
das team vorsicht durchgesetzt habe
angesicht eines osterloh gedöns von dem
vorher nie jemand gesprochen hat und da
steht die kanzlerin gesagt ja man soll
ja viel weiter als schon vor einem jahr
da kann man nur sagen ach nee weil wir
sollten ja auch in den letzten monaten
vielleicht ein bisschen was dazulernen
haben wir aber nicht wirklich weil wir
jetzt wieder diese pandemie mit den
waffen schlagen diese auch am anfang
gibt nämlich mit denen des lok downs und
dann sagt die kanzlerin
der erfolg wurde aufgegessen von der
mutation nein es liegt daran dass wir in
den vergangenen monaten nicht weiter
gekommen sind dass wir beim impfstoff
nicht weiter gekommen sind dass wir beim
test nicht weiter gekommen sind dass wir
bei innovativen ideen nicht weiter
gekommen sind dass wir bei allen bei
allen methoden die nicht mit lockdown zu
tun haben versagt haben und es wird
darüber zu sprechen sein welche
verantwortung auch diese drei politiker
dafür tragen dass diese entscheidung so
getroffen wurde wie sie getroffen wurde
und die frage die sie dort nicht
beantwortet haben ist wie es dazu kommen
konnte dass obwohl uns vorher
lockerungen zu ostern angekündigt wurden
am ende ist zu einem super lock down zur
oster gekommen ist offenbar ging es
darum dass die kanzlerin ausgangssperren
unbedingt wollte die die spd abgelehnt
hat aber auch markus söder wird erklären
müssen was dort heute eigentlich
passiert ist das hat er nicht erklärt im
gegenteil das war voll versagen und das
war schönrednerei des versagens mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schaue ich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren